to get to the villages around Sun Milan
you have to pass a checkpoint this land
belongs to the Sauk Finn agricultural
company here where local people used to
farm suck Finn is growing oil palms
it's a massive monoculture that requires
large amounts of chemicals in the middle
of it lives farmer Seema ma Tia he says
family members and local chiefs forced
him to lease his fields to suction for
decades hoping to profit from the deal
by receiving part of the payment but for
Seema Mattia it's been a disaster the
family that used to depend on this
plantation on this land we were over
over 50 in this village all now the land
is gone the money that they gave is gone
and living conditions are getting
difficult for us some environmental
activists call what happened here a land
grab a hundred twenty kilometres away
farmers soar he says se has not least
his land he grows palm fruit himself
along with other crops the oil palms
bear fruit for 25 years but since they
can only be harvested three or four
years after planting it's a long-term
investment 90s Kenickie I decided to go
into oil palm production nine years ago
this will be my pension we can harvest
it until I die
his family is large and they can harvest
the fruit all year round and the parts
of the plants that can't be used are
made into natural fertilizer these oil
palms are organically grown out of
necessity dr. de Vaca logistic Wedgwood
I don't use chemicals and besides I
don't even have money to buy any so we
rely purely on our own traditional
methods
today sorry SSA has a visitor it's
Mohammed Kamara from the Dutch palm oil
company natural habitats the group
produces its own organic palm oil fruits
but also buys from the local farmers how
long does it take you to grow a
plantation and then starts processing so
we decided to go straight to the farmers
who already have plantations and then a
system developed their skills ultimately
they increase their yield the company's
oil mill is close by oil palms are
high-yield giving four times as much oil
as sunflowers per hectare that makes it
cheap and widely consumed almost every
other product in supermarkets from
cookies to face creams contains palm oil
most of the raw oil pressed here is
exported but the amount is just a
fraction of that produced by large
companies can the organic coral compete
we can definitely compete with them
the reason being we have completely
different form of production we are
organic they are conventional and being
organic gives you a premium and a market
one thousand four hundred farmers like
Soros has say are part of natural
habitats network of certified organic
growers their number is set to rise as
world demand for palm oil continues to
climb